so guys I'd like to play a thing called
my first time first time you all met met
Akiva in Spanish class seventh grade and
then I don't really remember the first
first time I met Andy yeah it was
through Jason who's the ice Josh but
there was not a clear meet-cute so to
speak what's the first memorable
occasion with Andy that you can recall
probably 40s in the Rose Garden or
something yeah yeah we definitely was
just late night drinking in some sort of
a public park and we want to stress that
it's very important for kids not to
drink underage right we were about 16
years old drinking malt liquor in a park
and we don't want anyone to do that very
dangerous learn from our mistakes you
might end up becoming lifelong best
friends and getting to make movies
together
exactly don't drink it you can be famous
and rich thank you for saying that we're
famous and normal makes me feel really
good I don't know I mean compared to how
we were in high school definite yeah
yeah first time you realize you all
worked well together I mean have we
realized that yet I'm not sure we have
could be right now such a strange town
it's very cool I think maybe we'll
realize that in 2017 I'm realizing it
less interview goes I don't understand
what you're finding more later how about
first time you realize you made it in
the rap game I'd like to ask your
character yeah yeah that first time we
made it in the rap game I would say is
uh early 2002 maybe we nailed it
okay no I'm playing 1990 never 1999
first time you stepped into studio 8h
SNL you felt nervous nervous scared
sooner Jim well the first time was when
we just went to watch who's the Kiva's
now wife was a writer on the show and
got us in to watch dress rehearsal Colin
Farrell was the host and
was a hoot we were starstruck by just
the furniture big SNL fans first time
you felt like you let Lauren down a
little bit because it seems like that's
easy that's a good question for you
every week Thursday I was taken with a
lot there's a lot we made a short called
I wish it would rain and it was a little
bit over budget and many times during
the week told him that it wasn't worth
what it was costing and we shouldn't
make it and he was kept saying no it's
fine make it make it and then when it
aired during dress rehearsal he walked
by me in the hall and very sarcastically
it was like great job on the short like
I don't like five times yeah it has
become a staple in the writers room
SNL writers it started the tradition
started with Seth Meyers even after we
had left that when they were feeling
down they would watch wish it would rain
off the cenotes are possible yes we're
not possible
you